yes you out of your mind
I fire 143 pounds awful I was ranked
number 9 in the world at 145 when you
when you I didn't know too that the the
Mike diamond knockout that you had was
your last fight that was it
that was your last very last one you
want to talk about killing somebody yeah
I thought you killed him yeah you know I
wanted to but that was that was my first
Bellator fight I've ever seen or you
were there now I remember
oh not blasting [ __ ] [ __ ] out of him
it was a lot of emotion riding on that
one man I had um you know recently lost
my mom before that fight and I was kind
of you know I was just on one I was in a
little tailspin for a minute so they
reached out to me and was like I needed
something at the time and they hit me up
asking me if I wanted to fight here at
home and I was like I'm with that you
know and they uh they offer me my guy
man I knew they were trying to build my
garment up and I thought and I'll dust
my gun oh I mean let me get that way so
I actually had a three fight deal with
them but I told myself and I told my
family this would be the last one going
into it and I just walked away from the
contract on a win and I just I purely
did that last fight just to kind of like
vindicate myself you know what I mean I
just had to feel like I was on top one
more time and I miss it that was it he
was like 6 1 he's a lot bigger than the
big dude yeah I was really I was a big
underdog on that one man and he was kind
of he was bumping his gum a little bit
you know in interviews and stuff finally
he'd go to the a a little bit man they
tried this make me on one interview
where you know we're talking on on the
interview whatnot and then like he's on
phone to while they asking me questions
about him and [ __ ] you know that oh by
the way Mike's on the phone now I'm like
oh shut up yeah I'm like okay well I
said it you know that's what I'm gonna
do so it was a big win man it was a good
fight I was actually losing the fight I
lost the whole first round and we kind
of knew that was gonna be the case that
he was gonna come out Gauhar for a first
round and he probably gasps because of
the way cut and
well he kind of jumped in really awkward
into your head he did and he got crappy
and yeah just add a little extra little
sugar today that was like that extra
like told you brah what was he saying
what would you say pride to you guys
fighting um you know that I just never
fought at that level you know he's been
in the UFC and I'm like man you know
I've broke into the top 10 you know I
wouldn't beat some very formidable
opponents and here's the thing about me
you know win or lose you're not gonna
fight me twice I always tell people that
like you're you could beat me but I'll
guarantee you you won't say running back
yeah yeah and he was one of those guys
you know and I was like that retired him
that was it I they actually put the I
was on this de Netflix thing came out
called the hurt business they were
talking about that whole deal and that
whole fight and what was that was that
documentary about it was actually about
the injuries in the scrap wood be
highlighted yeah I heard that fools
brain fluid yeah yeah yeah they made me
out to be a [ __ ] bit lame even called
me and asked me about the [ __ ] that was
a cold fart oh really
they could have called and asked me I
could have told them that I felt
terrible could I be I feel terrible my
family no I felt great about that job
you know it once it was over I was like
five you know cuz he had to actually go
to surgery from the arena like we gotta
take you in right now
to go fix some [ __ ] and once I saw the
documentary I thought man they really
played me out to be the bad guy yeah and
didn't give me no chance to like talk
about it and say how I felt cuz I didn't
feel bad about it and you know my family
felt bad about it is like hey Mia we
don't want to see that happen to you so
I think you should retired I was my
mother-in-law she said I love this she
hated it at first but she became one of
my biggest fans yeah can't stand it at
first and after that fight she said I
just don't want to see that [ __ ] happen
to you you know I physically can't watch
a friend fight it's hard so after I
started just people start going to MMA
and then like even watching like like so
Andre sukham taught right like after I I
met him in person we started conversing
with each other after that
was hard for me to watch and fight
really it's just my stomach starts to
turn yeah like I get hit nerves
I get nervous for the nerves it's like
I'm in the cage and I'm like yeah like
when a buddy of mine runs goals then
when I saw him first no wrong you know
right we fought around twice right
we need that back so rod hits like a
[ __ ] hit me as hard as hey I'm not
gonna live me a funny rod story man cuz
I know you know Ryan and he fought our
boy this kid Chris Fajardo out of our
gym right him Iran in the ring man and
Chris since Ryan down like set him down
I'm like hell yeah we got him yeah they
were like you know he had beat our guy
before so he knocks him down crowd goes
crazy our guy runs over there to go
finish the fight right and gets up
cracks our dude our guy goes down it was
just one of those [ __ ] fights man I
was up high emotionally oh we got it it
was like I didn't ah and then Ryan
finished it but it was one of those
spectacular fight he's a beast man I
gotta I gotta give it to Ron hits for a
little guy he has heart I think that's
the thing that people don't expect that
yeah because he's a Caesar smaller guy
but everybody says the same [ __ ] about
him like it's like a [ __ ] yeah we did
that's like me I'm the same type of guy
like I can hit you know and that's what
a lot of people don't want to run up on
that because it's pretty crucial that
yeah when we when I saw I'm just
watching that fight like I feel like the
the UFC has changed a lot in terms of
like damage that if I